what are your thoughts about the
arraignment we believe it's a Witch Hunt
but we do believe that President Trump
is actually protected under the
continuity of government I believe he's
our authentic president and that we are
watching a movie
oh really so he's the current president
of the United States I believe that like
what is Biden doing then well Biden is
um we're under continuity
um action okay so this is where this
happens with every one of these folks
that Luke interviews as soon as you ask
any follow-up they start to look
confused about what's coming out of
their own mouths that's the commonality
the Common Thread between all of these